Kameron is back from Australia with an
update on a former dancing champ in the
Irwin we all fell in love with her on
dancing and now she is head over heels
and she talked to you about their
roaming and I've talked to bindi so many
times everybody's always asking her
about her boyfriend because they say
they are so in love but this is the
first time they've ever sat down
together to talk about it
so what do you guys learned about trying
to have a relationship in the spotlight
I feel so blessed that I actually
managed to find you kind of like my
soulmate like I am so grateful that I
found someone who it's challenging for
us just because our relationship has
been long-distance for a long time I
mean we met three years ago now people
are always wondering why by wearing
gauged or marry even people like me but
is that no marriage in the kind of right
now like like yeah that's that's years
and years away okay I think you've got
the same yeah I think so I think we're
just enjoying them now and just enjoying
being together bindi just turned 18 and
Chandler is 19 and I found out the
sentimental way Chandler one bindis
heart it happened after the day they
first met so I go and meet Chow like oh
this America guys okay then I didn't
hear from Chandler for quite a while
afterwards and that's because he sent a
letter asking my mum he could stay in
contact with me and then mom gave it the
letter to me and said this was passing
real and then we stayed in touch ever
changing the mood oh thank you yes honey
because after I had met her eyes I
really want to stay in touch but I don't
want to come across wrong or like I
think this is the best way to handle it
I'm gonna give it a go yeah I was
thinking that maybe today would be a
good day since we have the wonderful
entertain
tonight with us for you to start feeding
the crocodiles what do you think yeah
all right Chandler is now spending some
time in Oz and house a job alongside
bindi at the Australia Zoo and he's even
doing some of the exact same things
bindis dad Steve Irwin did like feeding
the Crocs and doing some wrangling for
research
I saw you jump a 15-foot crocodile yeah
it's bad girl you jumped ahead and I was
so proud one of them so yeah then your
name is Madison it's like dominoes it's
like bang bang bang bang why'd you say
go it's just you that's it you committed
don't go you're like putting everyone
else in jeopardy bindi gave me a tour of
the wildlife Animal Hospital and I got
some very hands-on experience at the zoo
you've now made a friend for life